today is wednesday wednesday is the day
that we always do these calls
um wednesday's a bit of a celebration
day for me as well
because we have winners on a wednesday
every single week in fact this
today this week we had gemma edens
on winners on a wednesday is gemma is
general on the call right now
gentlemen just give us just a little bit
of insight um what what what have you
been up to
what deals have you been getting i know
you've been keeping some things a little
bit on the low
um but now it's all out there so what's
been happening
yeah so um obviously uh i'll touch on on
the actual
um interview that i got made redundant
in
january well i didn't actually get made
redundant my contract ended so i was
working for a company for five years
um and then with the coroner and things
like that um
i lost my job at the back end of january
um and since then i've gone on to sell
five deals
uh totaling about 25 000
um and got a rent-rent service
accommodation which goes live
in a week and a half and that's also led
on to two other service accommodation
units went to rent with the same
landlord
um and yeah it's just it's going crazy i
sold a deal actually yesterday
so it's just it's just crazy i'll pick
up the keys tomorrow for another
property
um but yeah i just it's it's busy
it's um a touch on on how i got those
deals on
on the winners on a wednesday interview
um and yeah i just
i'm quite overwhelmed if i'm honest oh
that's fabulous
well listen we applaud you and also
not just your hard work and and your
results within property
but also your buzzing booming
personality and the fact that you share
so openly you always contribute and i
think as well
within this mastermind this isn't about
just joining just to get
yeah for sure you're going to get a lot
of information you can get a lot of
value but one of the things i love about
gemma and also lots of other members on
the community
is that people come on the calls and
these these sessions not just to get but
also to give
you know to inspire people to share what
they're doing to help and i know you've
you've always
you know been really really really
helpful to a lot of newbies they're just
getting started you've kind of taken
people under your wing
you've shared um you know as you've been
a few steps ahead
go ahead ben hello hi sam um
so i want to congratulate gemma first of
all uh i mean i've
since i've joined the about a month ago
i follow her story and she's done
amazing work and i think
she's a true example of what people can
do
second of all i did see all of your
videos when you're giving away your uh
your range rover
i know probably a lot of people spoke
about it uh when you're giving away your
house
and i don't know big thumbs up on you
and i hopefully you can do it soon again
just let me know where and i'll be there
uh the third the other thing is um i was
gonna add
um is i've had last week i had
a really really challenging week for
myself
so i was supposed to have two deals that
were going to uh
to be sold and if you remember i'm not
sure if you remember i also had the
development land
which i was interested into buying an
auction
now last week he was on bidding on
auction and what happened is for us to
work
we would have have we should have bought
it with
the maximum two hundred thousand pounds
now like that's like the top of what we
could
buy it for so we can get uh i don't know
a decent return on it
yeah uh that also fell through the
property was bought
with 260 000 so somebody really got
emotion in the last five minutes
yeah and it went from two hundred
thousand all the way to 260
from nothing so he originally bit 60 000
more
and he bought the property the land so
that was awful the other two prop
the the other two deals i had they also
fell through
yeah and it was a really challenging
week for myself now this week was
i think the total opposite of last week
i've literally come home probably about
half an hour ago
i've done a totally afternoon full of
viewings and at the end of it
i met a guy who's been in business for
the last 10 years
and we're um we're actually you know
discussing to
first buy a property and he's actually
got an also development
land in the same area where i'm looking
to buy the property and obviously source
the deal because it's not for myself
and uh the only thing i wanted to say is
just to shout out all the people who
probably struggling at the moment who
are probably not like
doing as well as gemma is doing or other
people
and i mean if you keep going at it just
like you said
uh good things will come and i really i
wanted to do this
last week but i was like you know what i
gotta have a comeback story so people
can actually be inspired to keep going
at it because
uh since i've joined i spoke to quite a
few not a lot of people with a few
people who are struggling
who are trying to give up and i'm trying
to keep their moral up
i'm you know trying to be their
accountability partners and what's
happening them and see how you're doing
what you've done this week
some of them they said you know what
i've done nothing this week especially
during the whole like three
four days during the the whole easter
thing
i mean you could have done a lot of
research during the entire but also
spend time with your family a lot of
people haven't done anything they
haven't anything planned for this week
and i know it's hard it's not easy i
mean we hear all this success stories
from you
from all the students and all the people
in the community
but you know it's not as easy as people
think it's not as easy as people think
and i know it's hard and i just want to
give a shout out to everybody who's
who's doing it and if you keep going
you'll definitely get it there's not
there's no rocket science
there's no magic trick to do it and if
you keep going to what samuel does i'm
sure everybody will get to it
yeah that's great and i think listen
persistence is really important
um with anything if if if it was just a
case
of oh well i'll just have a little go
and try and figure out and do a few
viewings then oh wow
three you know three days later suddenly
i've made 20 grand and
if if that was the case then every
single person
on the planet would be doing it everyone
will be an entrepreneur
everyone will be a millionaire and of
course it takes determination it takes
grit
and the interesting thing is that you
know people say to me is
is being an entrepreneur or a property
investor is it is it easy or is it hard
it's like well everything is hard having
a job is hard
being being overweight is hard and being
slim is hard being rich is hard but
being
poor is hard it just everything's
relative
but if you treat your business like you
treat a job
and and that you might think i'm going
to say oh if you treat your business
that you treat a job you're not going to
succeed because you need to make work
much harder in your business than you
would in a job no i disagree
i've only had a job once i worked as an
estate agent for bestow eaves
countrywide i did it for about three or
four months
oh my goodness i've never worked so hard
like they wanted blood
and while i was working for for
country-wide estates
i was just thinking imagine if i worked
this hard
on my own business but but people don't
do that because they've got no one
behind them
telling them they have to they just they
just they just think oh wow it's my own
business
you know anyone that says i'm really
struggling i've been doing this for a
month and i've not got any results i'll
say well how many properties have you
viewed
how many offers have you put forward how
many hours have you spent
actually on working on the business not
scrolling right move
and having cups of teas with your
friends how how you know
if you were your own employee if you
were employed by yourself
would you fire yourself or would you
keep yourself would you be like oh
they're a good worker
because a lot of us if we're honest if
we work for ourselves which we do
all right you'd be like okay you'd be
every week you'd be like right so what
have you done this week how many views
have you booked how many
and you've like oh wow i had three
viewings and
one of them cancelled and one of them
but you'd be like what are you kidding
me
are you serious so as soon as you just
seem to have an appointment with
yourself
every week um and acts like you work for
yourself you know why
because you do uh i don't know a lot
happening
so during easter i've been uh because
often i go
through the strategy to use right move
so during easter i told the landlords
maybe they were more relaxed so i i
called direct lenders
it was quite good so tomorrow i'm going
to see a landlord he wants to sell a
portfolio 100 properties
because he wants to invest in a really
big big business has got nothing to do
with property so he needs to really
release some cash and then i got the old
friend it's got
like an asset ages north so i'm going to
go to see him in the 13th
is god actually needs to source some
properties for he's got a small city
agent but it's going to so he needs to
source some property for some
a football some football players like
for
some of the players there so he asked me
to help him
so yeah fantastic that's really really
really good stuff exciting news
so top tips for building your investor
list graciela because i know you've sold
a lot of deals
um really think about small stuff
because people get
overwhelmed oh my gosh like how do i get
big numbers
small think small think one you
your goal is to get one every night so
generally at night
i go in all the forums or in the morning
before go to work
talk to people and then try to approach
them okay can i
and then when you engage with someone
they cannot improv a message can i talk
to you later
can i have your email can we take it
zoom call so that's why you do
just think one a day in a month is 30
30 by 12 months you got pretty much 300
investors
so i try to my goal is to list three
people sometimes five people
like i got their email their consent to
get my deals
every day and then it gets like in a
year a thousand small another really
interesting point as well on the back of
what graziella said is that you only
need
one good investor to go get a deal
you know it's not necessarily about how
how wide
your investor list is sometimes it's
about how deep it is
if you've got if you've got a rich list
i don't mean rich in terms of financial
i'm just talking like a really good
quality list
you might only have 20 or 30 but you can
be doing selling consistently selling
the deal a month
um so yeah really really really good
point very inspiring as always
david what is happening bro
uh samuel just literally the second just
after selling the deal for three
thousand pounds
so yeah and also today
today was actually a brilliant day so we
just sold the dealer now for three
thousand pound
i've met an investor today which has
given me forty thousand pounds
and i've also got an off-market property
today as well
from an agent what i'm looking at
tomorrow so
everything just went good today
fantastic
fantastic also as well really good to
see
joe jeremy cole great to see you as
always jonah cole is a proper legend
he's been with us now for a very long
time uh joe how's things going bro
okay matt everything's everything's well
good good what are you working on at the
moment um
i'm working on the rent to rent i've
found a deal now in in bradford i was
looking in leeds but can't find one and
then a family in bradford that's
that's looking good it's 200 so we're
taking it on
yeah sandra i was waiting for you to say
something it's so funny because people
message me instagram i'm like oh i just
got a deal i just sold it
and i always say share it on wednesday
night and then
i'll see them sheepishly on the call i'm
not sure
so good to see you what's happening okay
so i keep the keys up to
uh rents rent hmo in um east london
on the 1st of april 16th so while we
were talking about
london rent to rents and all kinds of
you were just quietly there thinking
[Laughter]
that's incredible congratulations that's
brilliant news
how much is that to be making you every
month okay
so um came the landlord two thousand
eight hundred per month
gross is three thousand eight hundred
and fifty
and the rental for each room is between
uh what the minimum 65
so how much you expected after
maintenance voids how much are you
hoping to make every month
cash flow um 700
great 700. that's really really good
well
sandra massive massive congrats mushtaq
i know mushtaq's got a deal recently as
well which is absolutely fabulous
uh how's that going mushtaq
hey it's going good to be honest yeah
better than i thought
i've got more opportunities as well
which i didn't really
think i'd fall into this rental rate i
was more towards uh
deal selling but uh what can i say
opportunity when it comes you're gonna
take it by its uh
throat so yeah yeah it's going good
um i've got another uh nine bedroom in
edgeway as well
um that i'm looking at but in this i
need to put in
a non-suite um basically in the kitchen
to make yourself contain
studio kind of thing but it's on top of
pubs so it's really good location
so i'm just weighing up the builders now
so to see how much that's going to cost
me
but there's a there's very good cash
flow on that one i think
yeah right well hey good good good and
we need to meet as well i'd love to come
around one of those so
definitely definitely drop me a message
[Music]